yeah i mean well we just got locked out
we got notified that we were locked out
last night we get an email that says uh
that we violated the rules for hateful
conduct um and they cited a specific
article of ours we're doing a satirical
take on
um you know the us usa today recently
naming
rachel levine a transgender individual
um as uh one of their picks for women of
the year so we did the satirical take on
this and and we named uh rachel levine
as our pick for man of the year um and
twitter didn't like that very much so we
ran a foul of their hateful conduct
policy and they basically notified us
they said look you know your your
account's not suspended um you just need
to unlock it you can unlock it by
deleting that tweet and we're like well
wait a minute
um you know deleting that tweet requires
that we uh agree that we have uh
violated the hateful conduct policy and
we don't agree with that uh we don't
believe that speaking the truth is hate
speech and you know satire does often
speak the truth it does it in a in a
humorous or ironic way um
but you know we stand by the point that
we were making in that article so we're
kind of at an impasse here where we
can't get our account unlocked because
we're not willing to delete that tweet
yeah we don't have any intentions of
deleting the tweet um
you know there are there are other
possible paths forward where we get back
onto twitter they do have an appeal
process that we can go through we're
looking at that um
we've been uh passed some contact
information for some people over at
twitter that we'll reach out to and
we'll try to talk to them they may yet
reach out to us because this is starting
to generate a little bit of media
attention we were trending on on twitter
all morning so
um i'm not sure
you know this may resolve itself uh or
we may resolve it going through the
appeals process we're not sure but we
don't have any intention at this time of
deleting that tweet